Dominic Robb now out of government
absolutely but that wasn't possible the
publication of this damning report
sealing his fate and forcing the Deputy
Prime Minister's resignation eight
formal complaints about his conduct
investigated by Adam Tolley KC two of
them upheld the fast from his time as
foreign secretary where his behavior was
found to be intimidating unreasonably
and persistently aggressive and his
conduct deemed an abuse or misuse of
power at the ministry of Justice 2
another complaint affirmed Rob found to
have acted in a manner which was
intimidating while his conduct was
insulting
that language and keeping with the
testimony I'd heard from some of those
who'd seen Mr Rob's Behavior
the way he would treat people but little
people interrogate people ignore people
he created an awful atmosphere they were
nervous about going into meetings with
him because they feared having strips
torn off them despite the verdict this a
reluctant resignation Dominic Raab right
into the prime minister to say whilst I
feel Duty bound to accept the outcome of
the inquiry it dismissed all but two of
the claims leveled against me he
continued in setting the threshold for
bullying so low this inquiry has set a
dangerous precedent it will encourage
spurious complaints against ministers
and have a chill-in effect on those
driving change on behalf of your
government Dominic Robb in his
constituency today trying to drive home
his defense
almost all of the complaints against me
were dismissed and what this doesn't
give you it's a handful of very senior
officials none of the uh junior
complaints were upheld and I got on and
dealt with hundreds of civil servants
thousands of other people in prison
service in the court service and what
you've got is the risk here a very small
minority of very activist uh civil
servants with a passive aggressive
culture of the Civil Service the PM
except in the resignation but clearly
pained responding it is with great
sadness that I have accepted your
resignation add in he'd always be
grateful for Mr Robb's steadfast
personal support and the dedication
commitment and loyalty he gave to the
role of Deputy PM for the opposition the
person to blame for all of this mess the
PM himself what I think this shows is
the continual weakness of the Prime
Minister because there's a double
weakness here he should never have
appointed him in the first place along
with other members of the cabinet that
shouldn't have been appointed and then
he didn't sack him and even today it's
Rob who resigned rather the Prime
Minister who acts early afternoon new
appointments came Oliver Dowden a long
time soon act loyalist appointed the new
Deputy pm and Alex chalk is Justice
secretary but Fresh Faces do little to
change and uncomfortable reality
in the end Mr Rob's departure was
inevitable after two bullying complaints
were upheld he had no option but to quit
but this is about much more than just Mr
Rob's career it affects the Prime
Minister too three of his cabinet
ministers have been forced to leave
government in the past five months and
you have to ask yourself is it really a
government of Integrity professionalism
and accountability while the prime
minister's backers will say that this
shows he's prepared to clean up his top
table others will argue that it shows a
serious lack of judgment that he put Rob
and others into his cabinet in the first
place
either way what Rob's departure brings
back to this place is a sense of Scandal
exactly what this new PM was desperate
to avoid bath rugby Sky News Westminster